dans le golfe depuis le début de la
crise de maille en bout il rencontrera
l'armée française
l'allemagne ne fait plus qu'une après la
fête et les flonflons d'hier la nouvelle
république fédérale va devoir désormais
se forger une nouvelle identité
kirk douglas acteur dans une centaine de
films metteur en scène réalisateur est
aussi un écrivain et romance il vient de
sortir son premier roman la danse du
diable kirk douglas est l'invité du
19/20 bonsoir la réunification allemande
et le départ de françois mitterrand dans
le golfe ce sont bien sûr les deux
grands dossiers de ce journal mais avant
de les développer
une information qui sonne comme un
triste destin le sort s'acharne sur la
principauté de monaco huit ans après la
mort de la princesse grâce le mari de
caroline s'est tué cet après-midi dans
un accident de offshore
stefano casiraghi avait tout juste 30
ans caroline since voici l'image que
tout se tiendront de stefano casiraghi
celle d'un homme heureux aux côtés d'une
princesse célèbre caroline de monaco
ils s'étaient rencontrés dans une boîte
de nuit monégasque avant de se marier il
ya sept ans ensemble ils avaient eu
trois enfants
l'italien homme d'affaires stéphane ont
été qualifiés dans son pays de jeunes
lions de la jet set
mais cet homme de 30 ans avait une autre
passion dans la vie l'off shore l'an
dernier il devenait même champion du
monde ce matin alors qu'il défendrait
son titre son bateau a décollé à 180 km
heure sur une vague et s'est retourné le
pilote est sauvée stefano lui est mort
sur le coup
la princesse caroline qui se trouvait à
paris est rentré en jet privé à monaco
le deuil frappe une nouvelle fois la
famille princière l'actualité en france
maintenant avec le départ ce matin de
françois mitterrand pour la région du
golfe c'est le premier voyage d'un chef
d'état occidental depuis le début de la
crise
françois mitterrand est arrivé il ya un
peu plus d'une heure à abou dhabi
première étape d'une brève tournée
d'inspection des troupes françaises qui
le mènera jeudi à lyon en bout en arabie
saoudite nathalie et r abou dhabi il ya
quelques heures françois mitterrand
vient tout juste d'atterrir à sa
descente d'avion
le chef de l'état est accueilli par le
cheikh zayed
président des émirats arabes unis c'est
la première fois qu'un chef d'état
occidental se rend dans le golfe depuis
le début de la crise une visite qui
résume assez bien la position de la
france dans ce conflit
fermeté et diplomatie fermeté car la
france est impliquée militairement dans
la crise
le président devrait d'ailleurs
rencontrer les 300 hommes du régiment
parachutiste de tarbes déployer abou
dhabi l'ips lomas également car ce
voyage est l'occasion pour françois
mitterrand de rencontrer chez eux les
souverains de deux pays directement
impliqués dans le conflit du golfe après
abu dhabi le chef d'état français se
rendra à djeddah puisaye en bout l'un
des ports les plus importants d'arabie
saoudite
il s'entraînera avec le roi fahd à paris
on espère que cette ville ne sera pas
perçue comme une provocation par bagdad
françois mitterrand était le premier
chef d'état occidental à proposer un
règlement pacifique de la crise
irako koweïtienne mais aussi de
l'ensemble du moyen-orient
demain le chef de l'état rencontrera
donc des militaires françaises qui ont
débarqué pour l'opération daguet le 19 à
vous proposera d'ailleurs une édition
spéciale en direct du port saoudien
émission spéciale sur la visite du
président de la république suivie sur
place par peu la mare avec bien sûr de
nombreux reportages la réunification de
l'allemagne ne fait que commencer
son acte de naissance est paru la nuit
dernière minuit dans un concert de
cloche chez devant un million de témoins
mariage de raison et fait de
circonstance la porte de brandebourg a
été envahie par un gigantesque défilé
mais les allemands enfin réunis se sont
réveillés ce matin un peu groggy
reportage à berlin de laurent andres
porte de brandebourg il est presque
minuit ils sont un million peut-être or
pur vidéo combien minutes encore je suis
encore citoyenne de l'ès 2 minutes après
je serai allemand plus rien qu'allemande
on va attendre ensemble
cette folle qu'il honnit bonne chance à
tous les allemands est prêt pour le
monde entier
00h01 le reichstag à 200 mètres de là la
nouvelle allemagne l'allemagne unifiée
monte pour la première fois ses couleurs
pour helmut kohl c'est le triomphe un
pays disparaît un autre fait ses
premiers pas en europe berlin que la
fête avec moins d'euphorie que
d'émotions peut-être pas de fièvre
nationaliste ici en tout cas et puis
assez de distance et d'ironie froide
pour être fidèle à ses meilleures
traditions
après cette longue nuit aujourd'hui les
berlinois ont un peu flotté toute la
journée
comme s'il ne réalisait pas encore ils
sont allés à l'église
écoutez bac puis sont venus se promener
ici ici sous les tilleuls unter den
linden leurs champs elysées à eux apaisé
et content content comme il ne l'avait
peut-être plus été depuis le début du
siècle
c'est demain que la vie politique
reprendra ses droits ici avec le
discours-programme de helmut kohl
demain on reparlera donc élections
chômage et crise économique
mais en attendant ici cet instant de
minuit la nuit dernière n'est toujours
pas terminée
quelques heures à peine après la
réunification helmut kohl le nouveau
chancelier de l'allemagne unie a tenu à
rassurer ses partenaires européens nous
allons nous engager pour l'unité
européenne avec la même détermination
que pour notre unification a déclaré
helmut kohl dans un message envoyé à
tous les gouvernements du monde
il faut dire que le géant allemand a de
quoi faire peur au reste de l'europe
hélène risacher près de 79 millions
d'habitants sur 15h10 à l'ouest 5 à
l'est et berlin la nouvelle république
fédérale d'allemagne est devenue la nuit
dernière la troisième puissance
économique mondiale est la première
puissance commerciale d'europe mais en
absorbant l'allemagne de l'est la rfa va
devoir payer très cher selon les experts
les plus optimistes
il faudra au moins quinze ans avant que
l'ancienne rda en pro au chômage nous
rattrape sa soeur de l'ocs l'ouest
coût de l'opération au moins 160
milliards de francs par an le prix de la
réunification sera le thème principal de
la campagne pour les élections générales
du 2 décembre prochain en attendant and
co
réalise son rêve diriger l'allemagne
réunifiée la capitale allemande et
berlin mais pour l'instant le
gouvernement continue de siéger la bonne
avec cinq nouveaux ministres venus de
l'est ce sans portefeuille
le parlement s'élargit de 144 députés
est allemand qui siègeront aux côtés des
5 119 de l'ouest jusqu'aux élections
depuis la nuit dernière l'ensemble de la
législation de rfa est étendue à la
nouvelle allemagne et l'armée de rda a
cessé d'exister
l'allemagne unie qui reste membre de
l'otan a prévu de limiter ses troupes à
370 mille soldats dont 50 milles
seulement issus de l'ex armée de rda
la nouvelle république fédérale
d'allemagne retrouve la presque totalité
de ses frontières d'avant guerre mais le
spectre du passé nazi et lulu taris
interdit tout rêve de puissance
après plus de 40 ans de séparation entre
le communisme à l'est et l'expérience
démocratique à l'ouest
les allemands ne se connaissent plus
très bien tout occupé à se retrouver ils
veulent conjurer le passé et s'intégrer
dans l'europe l'importance de
l'allemagne unis inquiètent les français
on l'a vu lors de récents sondages le
monstre économique et frais l'hexagone
ou plutôt les français moyens à rien de
tel dans la classe politique française
l'allemagne ne fait pas peur à nos
dirigeants certains même l'applaudissent
cheron qatar est allé recueillir les
réactions d'alain juppé françois léotard
et catherine trautmann
il y a un an les hommes politiques
français n'avait pas de mots assez beau
pour saluer la chute du mur de berlin
était à l'époque beaucoup d'entre eux se
rendait en allemagne comme pour mon
voyage initiatique sur les débris du
communisme mais tout est allé très vite
et aujourd'hui la joie affichée des
allemands à la joie affichée les
allemands pardon répond en france une
certaine inquiétude
alors faut-il avoir peur de la nouvelle
allemagne pour les responsables
politiques la réponse est non et tout
est dans la façon de le dire est que
nous ne devons pas la regarder avec
l'angoissent de celui qui vit ni se
regardant dans le miroir avec la fin de
celui qui a le courage de dire
j'assume cette image là et j'accepte la
compétition première casse noisette et
gorille est plus politique
alain juppé répond non mais non il ne
faut pas craindre l'allemagne unifiée
mais la france d'amour et en pâtir sur
le plan économique il faut dire que nous
sommes heureux de l'unification de
l'allemagne parce que c'est un peuple
qui se retrouvent et il faut se donner
les moyens de se battre je le répète
armes égales forte à faire il faut
d'abord commencer par laisser nos
charges qui ne pas créer des impôts
nouveaux
autre réaction autre exemple à
strasbourg catherine trautmann ne veut
pas partager ses inquiétudes pour elle
plus qu'un concurrent l'allemagne depuis
longtemps oeuvre et partenaires
économiques
nous sommes dans une relation
je dirais amicale de travail nous avons
beaucoup de dossiers transfrontaliers
qui font que pour nous c'est une réalité
simplement modifié mais depuis de gaulle
et adenauer en passant par valéry
giscard d'estaing schmitt et françois
mitterrand helmut kohl le couple
franco-allemand a longtemps fait
l'europe
et si aujourd'hui les hommes politiques
français affichent un certain pessimisme
c'est aussi sur l'avenir de la
construction européenne par bien les
aspects l'unification ressemble plutôt à
une annexion pure et simple de
l'allemagne de l'est par la rfa sur le
plan économique notamment 8000
entreprises sont à privatiser certains
noms déjà été reprise par les allemands
de l'ouest c'est le cas de l usine
automobile de zwickau dans le sud du
pays qui fabrique les célèbres trabant
tu volkswagen on a repris les commandes
il y a quelques mois et la polo
remplacera bientôt la trabi reportage de
nos envoyés spéciaux sur place claude
guaino et philippe basquin quel avenir
pour les trabant
avant il fallait passer commande 10 ans
à l'avance depuis l'ouverture des
frontières les prix ont baissé et on
peut se faire livrer sa trabant 9 sur le
champ mais pour le même prix les
allemands préfèrent de loin les modèles
d'occasion venus de l'ouest
chaque coin de rue de là où il ya une
place de libre il y a des voitures à
bord au début j'en ai vendu au cours des
derniers mois les allemands de l'est ont
acheté un demi million de véhicules
d'occasion un boom qui a fait grimper le
nombre des accidents de 75 % sont des
rousses qui ne sont pas faites pour des
voitures aussi rapide avec la trabant
cet appui relaxe au bar où vous savez la
trabant le meilleur véhicule que l'on
puisse trouver
tiens mais aujourd'hui les derniers
acheteurs qui restent sont des
excentriques comme cette hollandaise non
non on des courses automobiles sas les
polo de volkswagen s'apprête à prendre
la relève des tra bi les premières doit
sortir dans quelques jours d'une
nouvelle chaîne entièrement robotisés
l'atr abord elle fabriqué en 3 millions
d'exemplaires vie son crépuscule
la version de temps qui pétaradent elle
fumait et déjà abandonné
celle que l'on continue sa brique et on
lui sert moteur volkswagen sur leur
capot le prêt de 600 unités par jour en
mars dernier la production est tombé à
300 destinés à l'exportation
vingt-cinq véhicules avec la pologne
véhicule et jeté en l'air d'erreurs
n'auront pas une seule on nous promet
que tous les sports l'année prochaine
s'annonce dramatique la pologne et la
hongrie n'ont pas encore renouvelé leur
contrat
l'usiné condamné volkswagen 2 reprendra
qu'une faible partie du personnel oui la
plupart de travailleurs étrangers sont
rentrés chez eux
moi je suis encore là dieu merci pour
combien de temps on n'en sait rien de
frais de 12000 l'année dernière les
effectifs chez trabant tomberont à 6000
dans quelques mois sur les 9000 salariés
qui restent encore plus de 5000 sont en
chômage technique ne travaillant une
vingtaine d'heures par semaine devant la
gare de marchandises de checa au les
travaux s'entassent les clients se font
désirer un télégramme tout de suite qui
concerne la crise du golfe on vient
d'apprendre que saddam hussein ne s'est
rendu aujourd'hui au koweït
c'est la première fois depuis l'invasion
du 2 août dernier saddam hussein a
visité le koweït ce sont les termes de
l' agence irakienne ina des termes très
bresse saddam hussein a aussi rendu
visite aux soldats irakiens stationnés
dans le pays
en france conseil des ministres très
bouleversé ce matin à l'elysée on y
attendait la trop fameuse csg mais les
quatre nouveaux ministres issu du
remaniement d'hier lui ont volé la
vedette
quatre nouveaux élus qui ont pris place
pour la première fois ce matin autour de
la grande table du conseil parmi eux
georges kiejman et henri nallet
les deux ministres vont se partager le
pouvoir à la chancellerie
un tandem très imprévu pour la justice
déjà très touchée par une véritable
crise d'identité
halle berry pas menti un fauteuil celui
de pierre arpaillange pour 2 henri
nallet garde des sceaux en titre épaulé
par georges kiejman ministre délégué un
tandem du jamais vu place vendôme est à
peine installé leur calendrier est déjà
miné le 23 octobre juges avocats et
fonctionnaires de justice organise une
journée d'action
et ce n'est pas le simple renouvellement
des têtes à la chancellerie qui paraît
de nature à la journée
pure et simple il peut lui avoir la
grève du zèle
il peut y avoir toutes les formes
d'action qui permettront d'arrêter la
machine judiciaire est de faire
comprendre à l'extérieur que la justice
n'a pas réussi n'a pas trouvé sa place
dans les institutions de l'état et que
tant que la france n'aura pas une
justice indépendante avec les moyens de
son indépendance moyens statutaires
moyens matériels moyens en personnel la
france ne pourra pas se dire une
démocratie moderne attendre et voir
c'est la devise de l'ue sm le syndicat
majoritaire plus hommes pour rénover
l'institution après tout ce n'est pas
trop d'autant qu' henri nallet est un
politique on peut pas dire si ça va
marcher mais ce qui est important c'est
qu'un politique
en effet s'il faut il faut quitter le
caractère technique que le pain est
suffisamment grave pour que le politique
au plus haut niveau
s'engage sur ce terrain
pas de bénéfice du doute en revanche
pour les gardiens de prison le leader de
fo dénonce déjà ce couple de choc et
appellent le personnel à la re
mobilisation féminine en politique
toujours reprise aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale des questions
d'actualité des questions toujours très
suivi mais qui revêt aujourd'hui un
intérêt particulier et pour cause les
questions se sont transformés en examen
de passage des nouveaux ministres michel
lemaire la surveiller de près les
premières heures d'examen de deux
d'entre eux au delà des réponses du
gouvernement l'assemblée attendait avec
curiosité cet après-midi les prestations
du tout nouveau ministre leur de chacun
n'était pas encore venu et seuls les
ouïes mermaz et elisabeth guigou se
monter au créneau du gouvernement elle
appartient à monsieur le bd lieberman
dont blé et l'opposition se montre un
brin ironique mais la gravité du dossier
agricole fait rapidement disparaître les
sourires louis mermaz qui pourtant en a
vu de l'autre on était tout de même un
peu impressionné à la règle
c'est le répondre le plus le bruit
tranquillement question qu'on nous pose
eu la chance qu'on me pose des questions
qui étaient et sont calmes
un frisson dans cette misogyne
assemblées quand elle nous a dit guy do
monte à la tribune un peu émue elle
aussi elle s'en tire très honorablement
et ne se laissera pas impressionner par
les interruptions de ses contradicteurs
ça risque de se produire que vous savez
je regarde la télévision en temps mais
il est clair que ces nouveaux ministres
rencontreront dans les semaines à venir
une écoute moins indulgente au sein de
l'hémicycle
la csg et la contribution sociale
généralisée était présenté ce matin en
conseil des ministres et le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est qu'elle sème la
panique au sein des syndicats
tous l'ont condamné sauf la cfdt et dans
cette guéguerre des syndicats tous les
moyens sont bons de déclarations
enflammées en réponse acharnée la cfdt
n'a pas hésité à louer ce matin cette
mesure gouvernementale impopulaire par
l'intermédiaire de plusieurs pages de
publicité dans les quotidiens agnès
molinier le monde pour toucher les
cadres le parisien pour les autres la
cfdt s'offre dans deux quotidiens une
page de pub du jamais vu surtout quand
c'est pour vanter les mérites d'une
mesure gouvernementale la contribution
sociale généralisée un moment reprend à
son compte une proposition vous avons
fait depuis dix ans avec force ouvrière
le courant ne passe plus marc blondel
traité de menteur hier répond à son tour
à la cfdt pour lui la csg est injuste
mais surtout sa négociation devant le
parlement chaque année constitue un
risque majeur d'étatisation d'une façon
insidieuse pour l'état d'intervenir dans
la sécurité sociale et demain d'exiger
des choses vers son évolution qui ne
serait pas souhaitable pour les
travailleurs c'est tout le ministre de
la santé réfute bien sûr toute
accusation de mamie de l'état sur la
sécu aujourd'hui les décisions de
cotisation sont prises par le
gouvernement et par lui seul
demain cela sera débattu à l'assemblée
nationale moi je considère que la csg
c'est beaucoup plus démocratique que ça
ne l'était avant
pour la cfdt la csg est aussi plus juste
puisque elle touchera plus les hauts
revenus et c'est l'autre divergence avec
force ouvrière qui elle considère que
les chômeurs et les retraités vont payer
pour les actifs ne seront concernés par
la contribution sociale généralisée que
8 % des chômeurs c'est lire des chômeurs
qui gagnent plus que le smic est le seul
à conserver pour les retraités que 55%
donc il ne faut pas dire n'importe quoi
sur une question c'est important mais
derrière ce désaccord il ya le conflit
la sécurité sociale et les luttes de
pouvoir syndical la guerre devrait
continuer par médias interposés marc
blondel demande à débat télévisé sur la
sécu l'inspecteur jean jacques duffau le
suspect numéro un dans la sphère de la
disparition du pasteur doucé a été
libéré hier après midi une décision de
la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de versailles
rappel des faits explications d'une
libération dont la rapidité à créer la
surprise
huguette et philippe guinet 18 septembre
l'inspecteur jean marc dufour des
renseignements généraux est incarcéré à
la maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy
quinze jours plus tard hier il est
remise en liberté et placé sous contrôle
judiciaire est hautement la gare ces
rations a été brève
retour en arrière l'inspecteur dufour a
été inculpé pour avoir tiré un coup de
feu dans la porte d'un indicateur
récalcitrants gênant mais pas gravissime
seulement l'indicateur témoigne dufour
l'avait chargé d'infiltrer un réseau de
prostitution homosexuelle réseau qui
aurait eu pour source le pasteur doucé
l'indiquent refuse de contrat
intimidation de l'inspecteur on en est
là quand quinze jours plus tard le
passeur disparaît fait troublant
quelques instants auparavant
l'inspecteur a été aperçu rôdant près de
son domicile
mais du foie un alibi il était avec ses
collègues entendue par la brigade
criminelle la semaine dernière il met en
cause sa hiérarchie
des révélations qui ont motivé sa
libération selon son avocat c'est une
affaire qui résulte de l'activité un peu
étrange de versailles dans généraux
aujourd'hui
ou bien il ya quelque chose de
délictueux il nous prévient procureur de
la république et entretient la justice
on ne fait pas de la rétention
d'information parce qu'à ce moment là on
pense qu'on est en train de réunir un
dossier m'a pas pour la justice mais
paul chantage chantage qui aurait porté
sur des hommes de premier plan selon
maître vergès hypothèse non confirmée
mais quoi qu'il en soit la confusion
autour de cette affaire ne cesse de
s'accroître et une seule chose est sûre
les renseignements généraux se serait
bien passé de cette publicité
tout de suite les autres faits marquants
de l'actualité en france ce sont
françois grégoire
trois mille personnes ont organisé une
opération ville morte cet après midi
dans le centre de dunkerque pour
protester contre la grève des dockers
les 60 d'une entreprise utilisatrice du
port estime que cette règle pourrait
entraîner à terme à la fin du trafic
portuaire
le syndicat cgt des dockers protestent
contre le chômage qui touche aux
professions et les menaces qui pèsent
sur l'avenir du port de dunkerque
deuxième jour de manifestations avec
blocage du tgv un millier de lycéens du
mans qui demandent de meilleures
conditions d'enseignement dans les
lycées de nos villes
les professeurs sont solidaires et
demain les 7800 élèves du secondaire se
réuniront en assemblée générale pour
transmettre ensuite les cahiers de
doléances au ministère de l'éducation
nationale
250 caravanes et véhicules appartenant à
des forains stationne depuis lundi sur
le parking d'une grande surface de
garges-lès-gonesse d'après la direction
la clientèle ne peut plus accéder
normalement magasin une décision de
justice devrait entraîner une évacuation
des lieux par la force publique d'ici la
fin de la semaine
invité de ce journal calque de glace
comme douglas bonsoir doit-on encore
vous présentez vous êtes l'un des
acteurs américains les plus connus dans
le monde vous avez tourné en tout dans
une centaine de films avec des
réalisateurs prestigieux comme kubrick
minnelli preminger ou de palma mais
c'est pour un livre que vous nous vous
invitons ce soir votre deuxième livre
est votre premier roman la danse du
diable édité par olivier orban alors
coeur douglas écrivain est ce que ça
veut dire que vous allez abandonner le
cinéma
rassurez moi vous savez j'ai pensé que
je vais abandonner le cinéma parce que
ça mettrait beaucoup d'écrits un livre
mais j'ai reçu ce mail de la part des
deux savais qu'au stade et donc quatre
jours je vais commencer en forme enfoncé
ça me permet ce que je n'ai pas oublié
complètement que je suis un acteur alors
vous avez écrit un roman c'est votre
premier roman est ce que la rencontre
avec l'écriture d'un roman a été
difficile pour vous oui vous savez quand
j'ai écrit mes même mois d'abord j'ai
commencé la danse d hab
généralement il ya huit ans et dans le
monde
j'ai décidé d'écrire les mémoires et
après ça j'ai filé dans ce diable mais
moi je suis en train d autres romans
après le foot que je suis en train de
faire à nouveau un moment vous êtes très
occupé
pourquoi pas je suis jeune j'ai beaucoup
de fois je dois tout à fait de
travailler j'ai un jeune femme c'est
très important
ce roman que vous venez d'écrire la
danse du diable c'est un véritable cri
de colère contre quelque chose que vous
détestez qui est le mensonge
oui vous savez je crois qu'on doit le
mensonge qu'on dit à vous même ce pieux
est une religion qui se cache
qu'est-ce qui est là et moi c'est à
cause de ça
cela cause cette lgv congé d'un train de
le laisser que j'ai écrit mes mémoires
j'ai pensé qu'on doit prendre l'un 23
l'abattoir on dit ça l'un des trois
larrons terre
l'éventuelle inventaire toujours pour
savoir où j'étais où je suis et où
j'irai je crois que ça c'est le thème de
la danse diable ça vous a donc fait
réfléchir sur vous même exactement
alors rassurez nous vous avez dit vous
avez beaucoup de projets aussi bien dans
le cinéma que dans l'écriture
vous allez tourner en france est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire quelques mots sur
le film que vous allez tourner mais vous
savez j'ai fait sur le scénario
comme j'ai dit que yves castanou je
voulais jouer avec richard bohringer et
7 ans fument qui mènerait beaucoup parce
que c'est un sujet mais je joue
quelqu'un qui est le projet de nature
vous protéger la nature et c'est quelque
chose très peu de sens pour moi j'aimais
beaucoup de le faire
kirk douglas je vous remercie beaucoup
d'avoir participé à ce journal je
rappelle le titre de votre livre la
danse du diable un roman édité chez
olivier orban
voilà ce journal s'achève tout de suite
le rappel des titres de l'information de
la journée
départ de françois mitterrand dans le
golfe le président de la république
accompagné de jean pierre chevènement et
de roland dumas endroit visite demain
aux militaires français basés à yangzhou
allemagne nouvelle année zéro plus d'un
million de personnes ont fêté les minos
pour la rfa et la rda berlin ce mercredi
3 octobre marque officiellement la
renaissance de l'allemagne
quatre nouveaux ministres entrent dans
le gouvernement rocard pour inhaler
georges kiejman à la justice louis
mermaz à l'agriculture elisabeth guigou
aux affaires européennes et le barriste
bruno durieux à la santé
la principauté de monaco en deuil
stefano casiraghi le mari de la
princesse caroline s'est tué ce matin
pendant les championnats du monde off
shore à monaco il avait 30 ans et était
père de trois enfants voient la fin de
cette édition le prochain rendez vous
avec la rédaction c'est soir 3 bien sûr
à 22h20 a présenté par marc hautement
avant cela la marche du siècle de jean
marie cavada le thème ce soir bébé en
kit
quels sont les espoirs et les limites de
la procréation médicale assistée tout de
suite la météo complète de florence
klein bonsoir demain
m